very good afternoon to all of you and
welcome to the transmission of your new
best friend your relationship with the
genetics laboratory presented
by doctor carlos bacchi we are not
excited to bring this
educational virtual conference presented by la
cruz i
am cintia cepeda from brigham women's
hospital and  I will be your moderator for
today's session.
Before we begin, I want to remind you that
this event is interactive, so we
invite you to participate through
questions that you can ask during and
at the end of the talk. The questions
will be anonymous and you can send them by
pressing the green button  questions and
answers located in the
lower left corner of your screens we will
answer as many questions as
we can at the end of the
presentation also note that you can
enlarge the talk slides
by clicking on the slide icon
located in the lower right
finally  if they cannot see and hear the
presentation for  please use the
question and answer button and let us
know your problem
this is a virtual educational conference
and therefore offers
continuing education credits at the end of the
conference please click on the
credits button
located at the bottom
left of the page  page and follow the
instructions thank you very much and now i
would like to introduce doctor carlos de
chino carlos is one of the leaders
of the genetics service at texas
children's hospital and medical director
of the baylor cytogenetics laboratory
doctor baccino is
primarily involved in the
department  of molecular human genetics
in the area of ​​clinical genetics
actively participates in the diagnosis
and management of patients with
birth defects and economic diseases and
is a member of the skeletal dysplasias clinic
carlos is directly
involved in the training and
supervision of resident medical students
and interns like  The director
of the Claver Cytogenetic Laboratory
is particularly interested in the
structure of chromosomal abnormalities
and genetic diseases,
as well as the mechanisms that give rise to
such aberrations. One of his areas of
interest is epigenetics and
genetic imprinting diseases, in which he collaborates
with Dr.  actor duda and doctor
lisa annual for the study of children
with angelman syndrome and supported by
the network of the
enaitz rare disease research center
recently concluded studies
that used theine creatinine and
folic acid to promote methylation and
revert to the allele  silenced
this with the aim of reducing the
symptoms of angle mind syndrome
by altering
maternal patterns of genetic imprinting without further
ado I thank Carlos and it is time
for you to start your presentation with
Carlos
thanks for the presentation
at this time I am going
to  start my conference I wanted to
explain  r that this conference is going to
include a series of clinical cases to
try to try to demonstrate in a
more practical way the concepts that we want to
cover
during this talk
basically the topics to be discussed in the
presentation will be adhered to in
the information steps
that  are needed to obtain the
genetic studies
we are going to discuss the strategies
around how the studies are requested and I
also want to show you some
examples of laboratory reports the
vocabulary used in the
results reports and limitations in later
we are going to discuss a little more about
how  physicians, providers,
counseling nurses, and others
and others involved in the
medical care of patients can
help improve this type of
information,
and the benefits of sharing that
information to improve genetic testing
in terms of indications for
genetic testing can be varied.  and of those
of that indication will  depending on how
and what type of studies are done on
patients obviously if we are talking about
a study that is done at the prenatal level
to the parents to see the presence of
genetic abnormality export with
a study can be done because
fetal abnormalities have been found by
ultrasound  And in the specific case,
for example, a child who appears with
presents with deafness, the child who
presents with learning difficulties
in problems of congenital heart disease,
family history of cancer, that is,
the indications for a study are
multiple and the indications will
change.  what types of what type of
studies are performed on the patient in
particular and I also want to give you
some examples of what are the types of
studies we are talking about
obviously doctors can always
count on the help of their regional laboratory
surely in the laboratory or in  the
nearby hospital or laboratory
you work with has trained personnel
If I am a medical geneticist counselor
geneticist pathologist counselor who can explain
what are the studies
available in that laboratory and when
I know what are the ideal studies to
perform on the patient
in terms of the subject you
are interested in, it
is also important to know
if you  they request a study what is
the cost the sensitivity is study and
as well as the
detection percentage study appears
for example there are studies that can be
done in a timely
manner in a staggered manner
the example is the study for deafness if
we have a patient who presents with
deafness
There are neurosensory genetic studies that are
generally requested at the beginning that
can detect a large percentage of
those patients, for example,
mutations in connection with 26 al are one
of the most frequent causes of genetic deafness
in patients who present with
non-syndromic deafness or  be that in this
type of case it is convenient to tr  tie to
request the
specific study for connection to amd and in the
event that it is negative
the doctor can request a study of a
panel and there are different types of panels
but the panel has a slightly
higher cost, that is, one can
start small and then gradually
increase the complexity of the specific study,
for example one can also do
micro retro homophobic studies uex or
more and then continue completing
studies with other studies studies on hair removal
studies for triplet expansion,
that is, actually in the study  it is
going to be managed
by the clinical indication
also a very popular study and we are going to
talk now a little about that is the
study of exorns but it must also
be taken into account that sometimes the
symptoms are not
the ideal studies  For certain types
of pathologies, for example, this is a
list of the genes that are
involved in the different types of
genetic deafness and the two
genes that  they are very frequent in
genetic deafness none of these genes
are detected with exome studies,
that is, for this type of evaluation,
specific studies must be carried out for
these genes.
more
information
and it was also followed by
a panel study,
that is, these genes, which are the most frequent genes
that are associated with deafness, are not
included in the more sex, that is,
you have to have and you have to be careful because
depending on the type of  studies one
may think that this is going to cover
all types of diseases but it is not
the case
in what elements must be considered
for the request for genetic studies
well one has to see if the
medical insurance covers not the
study sometimes multiple studies  may have
a higher cost than a single
complete study in that case one can think of
seven thousand studies in the same way at
the
speed with which cu  When the study is required,
for example, certain studies,
for example, prenatal studies,
require a speed and
that can influence the type of
study, although it is requested, as in the
case today, we can do
exo more critical studies, which
take the sample.  of the fetus and the
parents
and can be informed in
approximately two to three
weeks regarding the type of samples
most of the samples used for
genetic studies are blood
there are exceptions and the exceptions are
sometimes we can take saliva or blood samples
to be recorded buccal when we want to
do studies of point mutations
in the case of studies that have to do
with cancer sometimes we directly
study the sample or biopsy to
prenatal studies that require
other types of tissues such as
chorionic villi or placenta or  the
study of amniotic fluid
and in some special cases such
as autopsies can be  use
certain tissues although many times those
tissues may be damaged
by lack of oxygen or tissues that
have been exposed to formalin or
fixatives that have been used to
preserve those tissues in some cases
clotted blood can be used
for genetic studies
because saliva  Saliva is not routinely used.
Although it is
good, it is a good sample, but
generally the amount of DNA that can
be extracted from a sample is
insufficient. For some types of
studies
, a larger amount of DNA is required and
there are also problems with  contamination
and there are problems with the quality
of the dna that is obtained from
the samples the saliva samples
the other thing that must be taken into account
is
the consent in the information that
is provided to the patient about the
study of the study process
the clinical information is very important
that it accompanies the sample sometimes in the
laboratory it
guides us and can help us  help to try
to focus in more detail on
what are
the possibilities of pathology and these
help us to improve the
interpretation and also help us to
offer the most
appropriate recommendations for studies
and follow
-up from the laboratory's point of view the
laboratory cannot recommend care
doctors, that's what the doctor is for, that
's what the specialist is for,
although these studies are required, the
laboratory has to report and it has
to give information that helps the
doctor to make a decision, one of the
things that we are going to discuss in the
next few minutes
when the  The doctor informs about the
pathogenicity
of the specific genetic alterations
and that will also help the doctor to
make a determination about
genetic counseling and counseling.
The interpretation of the results
in this sense is very important when
we talk about variations that are
found.  In a genetic study
we make a classification to
determine  to determine if this variant is
significant or if a gene is not interrupted
or a protein function is altered
and eventually what is the
impact on the clinical phenotype
in terms of interpretation and
good recommendations based on that what
is
the recommendation that I make for  the
patient is based on that
protein or genetic alteration and it is also
important to know if there are recommendations
established by the medical community
for that type of pathology or genetics and
also what needs to be done for
follow-up in I want to show you a
case that is a study  that was done in
our laboratory this was a prenatal study
in the case it is a
male fetus that had a
copy a loss of copy number in
the next 2 which is the gene that is
related to red syndrome is
lost within the gene  It is inside an
intro
but obviously, as you know,
Neste 2 is associated with network syndrome,
which is an
extremely severe pathology, especially  what
affects women but it can also
affect men
in this case what was done is a
study of the root of the
patient's mother and they find that the mother
has the same
alteration where you have that loss of  injury in
the people of mex buts
again in this in this case I am
indicating to the
different samples of the child that is or
the fetus that is above and the mother
that is below both have the
same the same direction
obviously the mother is  heterozygotes the
child has only one x chromosome
and here at the bottom in the loss
of the oligonucleotides that show
which is
in the bits of DNA that are
involved in this genetic loss
in this case what happens is that
the network and  the micro king of the end of the
pregnancy is informed,
then we do it at the root of the
mother and we also see that
the mother has the same lesion,
so in this case it is discussed with the
different professionals of the lab  oratory
to genetic counselors or geneticists and the
couple is explained that the finding is
probably benign, although one
cannot guarantee that it will not have a
clinical peak, for this reason
other studies or family studies must be done and
the problem in this case is that the mother
She was very anxious and considered the
possibility of terminating her pregnancy,
so they offer to do studies in the
family
and the study is done on another normal child
in the family who is 18 months old
and the study shows
what is normal, that is, it is u  another man
has no problem,
so the family study is expanded
and a real one is made and in the maternal uncle, that
is, in the mother's brother and in the
maternal uncle, it is also normal, that is,
now we do not
have much more information  of the family
but finally what is done is
asked to make a king in the paternal
grandfather is in the father of the mother and it is
found that the paternal grandfather has
the same alteration as  it is found in
the mother that is found in the fetus that
was later confirmed by the ipea
so this
gives us a little more peace of mind and in
this particular case the pregnancy was
continued and we can say with certainty
that it is not associated with a
pathological alteration  or pathogenic
what happens in the laboratory when
we are informing copy numbers to
copy number variations
we have different qualifications or
classifications to identify these
those alterations
in the benign ones are those or those
alterations that have been reported
in the literature and that are
established  in number of
publications and databases as
alterations that are not associated with
pathology and that do not have a
clinical consequence
is important
on the other hand at the other end
are the copy variation numbers
that are pathogenic these are
cases of variations that  we know are
associated with pathology have
penetrance and express  known severity
and pathogenicity is not questionable and
also generally includes all
those visible alterations that are
cytogenetically visible
and that we know to be associated with
pathology
those that are more complicated are
variations of uncertain meaning
and these variations of
certain meaning are those that  sometimes we are
careful in informing because at the
moment, although they are reported, there is not
enough information to determine
what the clinical significance is, that is, what it
may be pathogenic, but the
reality is that one cannot determine
if it is of a pathogenic type
and in some  cases can become
benign,
this
is one of the most problematic cases
that we understand in the laboratory,
so we generally have to
justify our
opinion based on known information, but
the reality is that regardless
of our opinion there is always
uncertainty as to  to the
final classification
when you have  In this category of
variation,
we can also classify them as
low risk, significant risk, and
those between medium and low risk
are when there are alterations in which
there are no genes in the interval,
but they are generally informed by
the size they
are described.  doing a small
number of controls and in databases
and not apparently associated with
pathology
then there are the uncertain ones that have
a significant risk in this case they are
duplication it is about lesions where there
may
be compromise in certain genes that
we know may be altered and  that
can alter the gene but in this type
of cases there are generally very few
publications or sometimes a simple case has been
described in the literature
but there is concern about the phenotype
that is relevant in the patient
and what is perhaps the most
complicated category is the uncertain one  without qualifying
and this is the case where we do not have
information
from the literature, there is also no  There is a lot of
information in the public databases
and the genes involved may or may
not be associated with changes in the
fields, their function is uncertain.
In this category, the
genes called
variable expression and reduced penetrance also fall, which are
incomplete penetrance to these concepts.
o reduced penetrance is when a
person has a genomic variation
but does not show the disease
that is a person who has incomplete penetrance
is will preside variable is when the
clinical manifestations can be
variable in an individual from mild to more
severe and that can be seen in the
different members of a family that
have the same alteration in particular
how we handle this type of situation
we handle it with information from the
literature and we handle it with information
that appears in databases for
example for variations in
copy numbers
there are different bases  of data such
as one called kaiser that n  It
allows you to obtain information
from other patients or individuals
reported to
in this database that is
compressed by many laboratories
around the world
and that explains whether there is an association with
clinical alterations in each particular case.
I am not going to dwell too much on this
in this graph.  because you
also have it, you can look at it more
carefully and then in your pdf but this
is exemplifying you in the table that
is on the left it exemplifies
the different
different 100 appearances
comparison number of the number of copies that
are associated with different  chromosomes
and lesion duplication
that has a
different penetration because it is something that has already been
seen in a different family, for example,
in some cases in the first case there is
the
in this case there is a
proximal duplication of a1
where there is a penetration penetration of
approximately 17  % that means that
a father or a mother that has that
duplication can be completely
non  Normal but having a child that has the
same duplication but has more
manifestations
on the right is the graph that
shows you, for example, the elections in 16
and here I share
individuals who have the election 16 p
11 and in the case in the in  the
left part of the graph shows the
IQ of the people
with the lesion on the
right part that is in blue are the
people
from the same family who do not
have the bone alteration and that is what
it is representing  It is that in
the same family there may be
differences in the
IQ related to
these variations in the number of
copies.
The other study that
is frequently carried out in the laboratory is the
study of six or more sex threads, more
are studies that are carried out
looking at the information of all the
exons which are
the genes that code for the proteins
that we know of and are associated with the 20
thousand genes that we all have
in n  ur organism this is a
very popular study
I want to remind you that the exons only
represent 1
point five percent of the total genome
the variations that we find in the
study of the exome are then
interpreted based on
databases and based on the clinical report
to  cables shows in this slide
what are all the steps that are followed
when an exome study
is reported in the laboratory and the
process is quite complex but
basically it goes through a series
of databases that determine
if the genes in question or the
variations  are pathogenic or there
is not an initial review by one
by a director of the laboratory where
the different variants begin to be identified
, different filters are applied
, the associated literature is seen and an attempt is made
to classify whether the variants are
associated with some type of phenotype or
pathogenicity and when
This type of steps are already determined, confirmation is requested
by what is called
sequence  ance blood type in and after
that of that level of study
is reviewed
by another person who already has more
knowledge of genetics and generally
begins to make comparisons of the
study of the individual and in
most cases also the study
of the parents in  Based on that, later
on, finally carried out by the
medical director of the laboratory and the sample
ends up being reported
and in the case of the report of the sexes, plus
we in our laboratory
classify the variations of group
number 1, number 4, number 1 has
the  pathogenic variants number 2
has the two groups:
possible pathogenic variants and variants of
uncertain significance, although in it they have an
indication of possible pathogenicity;
later, we also report the actionable variants
not related to the
phenotype
and there is a small difference between
the postnatal studies that we do  and
the prenatal garments because in
category 3 in the penalties we have to
go  Variants that cause disease but are
generally not related to
prenatal variances but can
cause disease in adulthood or
in childhood
In this graph I show you the number
of variations that are typically
found in an exome sample at
approximately  there are 400 to 700 variants
in each sample
and after all the filtering and
after all the analysis we
basically
establish the pathogenicity of
certain variants which are normally
between 0 and 2 and the related variants
between 4 and 9 and we also have other
variants like  those that are
actionable from the medical point of view to
characteristics that sometimes have to
do with
recessive picasso carriers and variants in
pharmacogenetics
when we study the exome
we have also found that in some
cases of patients
with more complex presentation it can
There may be
variations involving two genes
or two mutations
that appear in  independently
and what happens in this type of case
the clinical alterations are very
diverse and often severe and
so they do not fit with a pathology
for quality end up
making the result of two
different pathologies in our laboratory
more than 5000 studies have been done on the  exome and
in our experience approximately
between 5 and 6 percent of
patients have had 2 or even more
diagnoses,
although they are associated with a genetic mutation,
I want to show you the case of a child
who presented this little boy at 9 years of
age  He presents with
weakness problems
with breathing problems with apneas He also
has other muscular symptoms with cough and severe
dysphagia and this
the child was diagnosed with
cardiomyopathy at 8 months of age
the family history of seeing that the
youngest sister died  at 20 months with a
febrile episode and also
apnea problems and in this case what
the study found
or exome shows that this patient
has two mutations in this gene
called rap without the gene is associated
with myasthenia congenita syndrome
and this is a recessive disease that
is characterized by
bilateral toxic problems limb weakness affects
skeletal muscles  and this explains
the presentation of the child with apnea with
muscle weakness and with these
clinical problems with which I present this type
of disease can sometimes be
successfully treated with the use
of acetylcholinesterase inhibitors.
What was also interesting is that
in  another mutation was detected in the patient
and this mutation was a
pathogenic mutation in a gene called abc
9 sometimes 9 is a gene that is
associated with dilated heart disease
and this gene is the one that most likely
informs us that the minister  that
presents with a cardiomyopathy is
associated with a mutation in this
particular mother was
also sequenced and it was seen that  e she
was an atheist if she votes, that is, at that
moment she is indicated or advised
to go see a cardiologist because if
she does not have cardiomyopathy, she may have
a problem of that type,
that is, in this case,
there is a point of correlation  Clinically, the child
presents with the vocations two
recessive mutations in the zinc rap
and also surely the sister
who could not be studied because she
died is most likely had
the same disease and on the other
hand we have the cardiomyopathy
that explains us  the initial diagnosis
of this of this child and the possibility
that the mother is
affected
the interpretation of the exome and obviously
it is important
but the interpretation helps us to
see certain alterations that sometimes
we can detect but as I
explained at the beginning there are  other types of
genetic alterations
that may be associated with other
genetic mechanisms and not necessarily
be
detected by  r the study of the exome,
for example, in there are situations where there
may be genetic imprinting problems
or even parental dystonia variations
and then we have to be a
little careful when an ex or malady
is reported as negative because
sometimes there may be
I show you another case of a patient that
I saw a few years ago in the clinic,
this is the case of a man who presents
with a developmental delay, significant intellectual ability,
autism and low
muscle tone and has some
characteristics
that we call it dysmorphic he
also had
cryptorchidism with him
an undescended testicle
and later also presented with
precocious puberty
studies in this boy were
quite complete include
hair removal for prader willi syndrome
and studies for
fragility syndrome of the x
micro rey metabolic studies and these studies were all
normal here  I show you the
family tree and with
the arrow the patient
in question is indicating that it is a male as you
see this child had a sister who was
premature and died at nine months of
life and had many many problems in
addition to her prematurity  and this little
girl had it
as effective
and the interesting thing in this family was that
there were also some cousins ​​on the
father's side who were
affected with, in one case, a girl who
had very similar characteristics to the
boy she consults and later it was
also found that there was another  little boy who
died at 8 weeks of life
apparently of sudden death
in this case the study of the exome
shows a mutation in a gene that is
implanted
it is called the image you
to image 2 that is in the same region
of prader willi syndrome has
characteristics similar to
prader willi syndrome
and in this case it was found that
the duplication of our alteration in the
gene came from
the father
when  we did more studies of him
from the family so we see that the
father exporter of this duplication
the brother of the father exporter of the
duplication none of them are affected
because this is a paternal conflicting gene
but the same gene was also
present in one in the grandmother
by  part of the father to studies
studies that were carried out after the fact
showed that the other is the
uncle's daughter also had the same mutation,
in this case the genealogical length
is very important to be able to
interpret and put all this
information together and this is  a little more
detail at the time we reported
the alteration in question there were some
other cases
that were reported with this which this
same
type of mutation this is a disease
that
has actually been identified in the last 2 or 3
the other thing that  I wanted to comment, it is
everything that has to do with the
coverage of the micro rey
studies. The micro rey studies detect
variances.  in the
case of our laboratory this is a
scheme of a typical gene in this case
the neuropsin 1a gene as the gene
is covered and you do not notice that
where
the different exons are there is greater
coverage of the  of the regions
where the oligonucleotides are located, but
we also have very good
gentronic coverage. In this way, we
guarantee detection of small
anomalies,
although in another way they can escape and
that many times a study such as the
study of the sexes cannot
report more
is a case.  to illustrate this is a
case of a girl who presents with
congenital malformations
pitt morfil same facial orgies
has three closure to 13 anal
reflux of renal reflux and a lot of
importance' syndactyly
skeletal abnormalities towards normal cardiac days
this patient showed a
lesion called  fm 58
as you can see in the graph,
the circle is shown here in the
direction that is shown
below  It is showing the reliefs and those
that are involved in this
particular direction in this case only
involve a nexus
of this gene
although this
has now shown with the arrow to the
red arrow
and it turned out that this patient has
a lesion in this  gene that causes this
pathology known as
sitting syndrome this is an extremely
rare
x-linked dominant pathology and has
all the characteristics
basically similar to those presented
in our particular patient this is
from a
publication by dr. hunger which was
what
In general, this pathology is in the
literature.
I want to show you another interesting clinical case,
which is the case of a girl
who presented with combined immunodeficiency.
In this case, the exome shows that there is
an apparently homozygous mutation
where there is a small duplication within
the
d
7 r gene.  which is a Chinese inmate
this is a mutations in this gene
are associated with
this pathology of imm  a
combined deficiency although it is
normally excessive and is
associated with pathologies or
recurrent infections and infections with
microorganisms
this is
the summary of the results
on the right of the top
show the patient's mutation where
is
this duplication apparently  or a musician
is in the case this study is done
on the mother and the mother is normal, that is,
we expected a
recessive disorder where the father and mother
share the same disorder, the
norm is normal and the father is found
to have the disorder  I know, but if it
drops, that is, the father has one
chromosome and the normal gene and the other
chromosome has the mutation, the
duplication inside the gene, as we
explained this in this case, after the
study of the exome and having this
result, the study of  micro
rey to the patient and it is shown that the
study of micro reid has such a loss
that it involves a single exxon of
this same gene of l  to interleukin to
the interleukin
number 7 receptor and the arrow is showing
3 oligonucleotides that are interested
in this particular patient and what
happened is that the breast
also shares the same lesson that
happened in this case it is very simple the  exome
detector the duplication or mutation in
the gene that is a duplication within the
gene that is present in the father the
father touches wombs and gorka or carrier
of the disease and the mother turns out to
have a choice within the
same gene in  lesson number 3
the patient who is
indicated as affected ends up
receiving two mutations from the
mother's and father's breasts, although they explain the
recessive nature of the disease
what happens if a genetic study
is not conclusive,
obviously stopping the
genetic study that is requested  Detection can
be highly variable between 1% and 60%.
We have already explained a little
about microarray variations and also in
the case of s  exo + d
where are the variations of
is true in this type of case what
is important is to do
parental studies the study of the parents if
familial studies are available to determine how
the disease and whether the
particular variation segregates with the
disease
or  also in some cases to do
clinical studies to determine or
identify specific elements
based on the predictions of the gene it
can be a study of the metabolism it
can be an electrocardiogram it can
be a study of different types of
clinical studies that help us to
clarify
the information
what is the role  of the
physician's laboratory in following these
recommendations and studies. The role
of the laboratory is to provide the best
information to resolve, not to the
interpretation of these variants of
uncertain significance,
to try to resolve whether the variants
are pathogenic and also to provide
information for management.  of pathologies
associated with alter  pathogenic ation or
mutation-associated disease the role
of the physician is different the role of the
physician is to make clinical management decisions
based on the
clinical correlation of the genetic studies
and obviously considering the
individual situation of the patient of
intercurrent internal diseases
session prognosis of the  patient etc.
what are the benefits of
sharing the information on the results and
comparing with the variants that have
become a very important
and necessary element for the benefit and
safety of the patient and how to encourage
this practice
I am commenting on this because
and we are  There are many
laboratories in different parts of the
world
that base their information or the
information from this on their report or
report based on the information that
other laboratories have deposited
in databases or in places that have
public access and many times it happens
that  there is information that some
private laboratories have  have
and that they do not share with others,
with other laboratories or with other
databases,
so one
tries to see what is the way, what is the
solution for the interested parties and
the consumers,
what we propose, especially
those of us who are working
in the academic part  It is in terms of
research to work with
publications that require depositing
information on pathogenic variants and
databases that have public access
today, many
scientific or medical journals
request that an article on
a patient x
or a family that has a mutation be published.
They ask that as part
of that delivery of that
from delivering it to the journal that
this information be presented or deposited
in some databases and also the
other way is to try to pressure the
organizations that accredit the
laboratory so that the laboratories
deposit these variants in and as well as
always interpretation and that it be one
that is part of the control  l of quality
for laboratory accreditation
in terms of hospitals, clinics and
health providers,
what you can do from your
place is request laboratory studies
from places that share the variants
with others in the case of insurers
and also require that the
interpretations of the variants are
provided
and in the case of regulatory bodies
such as equity in the usa
is
and try to make them qualify
the studies of laboratories that do not
share interpretation and that are
considered as high risk
obviously this
is a sum  of ideas is not something that
normally happens but it is something
that we would like to see happen in the
future to be able to help with all these
variations of interpreting
uncertain
I think that at this moment I am going to
close my talk
I think I am going a bit too far  of
time I thank you very much for your
attention and I would appreciate it
if you have some questions and
we can ask them  now or we can
discuss them at the end of the session and if you
need them in the future you can
send me an email to the address that is
listed on the slide
thank you
very much thank you very much carlos for being very
interesting presentation now is time
for questions and answers if you have
any questions what would you like to
do doctor from china please
let us know right now
click on the green kye gwan icon at the
bottom of the
presentation window and once written
click send we will answer as many
questions as  we can
the first question is why keep
doing gene microarrays or panels
and instead use exo plus
for all diagnoses carlos what do
you think about it
now it
's not simple it's not uncommon for
people to ask for sex more and not even  requests
microarray studies the study of
the sex plus one detects
chromosomal microarrays there are some laboratories that
do
a sneak arbey that they do it as part
of the quality control but they do not
report variations in the number of
copies for example the case that
exemplifies this patient who
presented with the
interleukin alteration in this patient there was a
single mutation and the second mutation was
discovered  for doing the study of
microarrays, that is, the study of
microarrays in many cases when
a recessive or dominant pathology was suspected
at birth that is associated
with a single mutation is important to
perform
because one may be considering that
the exome  it will give you all the
answers and it is not like that, that is,
the study of microarrays is very important
in terms of the panels, it depends on the
situation, for example, for deafness,
we generally ask for panels
because there are many mutations that
are in places in parts  of genes
where they are not encoded or
copy number variations that panels do
not effect so  The panel is important
and if I do a study
of deafness and connection to negative medium and
the panel to negative medium then well
maybe I have to consider the way
to look for mutations in genes
although they are not known there but it is
more at level and more in  investigative search
but the panels still have their value
and their place in certain types of
situations although the reality is that
little by little they are being displaced by
the former form but that is not why it is
important
that when
a health provider wants a
genetic study that they consult  or to interact
with the genetic counselor or the
medical director of the laboratory to find out what
is the best study that they can perform
perfect thank you very much for this
answer we are on our
time limit unfortunately so if you
have any more questions please
go to the question area  and answers
or in the networking lunch and there is a
Chinese doctor channel
I would like to thank you once again Carlos
for  your presentation and if you have
any final comments for this session
on human genetics and american society of
human genetics for giving me this
opportunity
to give birth to this conference and
connect with you
sorry that the talk has lasted a
little longer than I wanted so I'm going
now to the lounge to answer any
questions you may have
thank you very much without percussion
thanks to you carlos for this excellent
talk once again this is a
virtual educational conference and
therefore offers continuing education credits
at the end of the conference
please click on  the
e credits button located on the
bottom left of the web page and
follow the instructions before leaving
I would like to inform you that this
virtual conference will be available
as video on demand until
September 22 of this year you will receive an
email from  the
roots that will let you know
when it will be available please
Please share this announcement with your colleagues
who have missed the opportunity to see
this event live. You are now
invited to join Dr. Baccino in
the connection room. Once
the session is over,
Carlos will be answering any more
questions and concerns you may have. You
can access this  room through the
logo and use the live chat where you
can enter your questions
thank you very much for having attended this
event we hope to see you soon and
have a nice day until next time